- [Instructor] In this
video, we're gonna build
on what we already know
about aggregate demand
and aggregate supply,
and the Phillips curve,
and we are going to connect these ideas.
So first, the Phillips curve.
This is a typical Phillips
curve for an economy.
High inflation is associated
with low unemployment,
high unemployment is
associated with low inflation,
but we can really view this curve
as the short run Phillips curve.
Short run Phillips curve.
We might sit at different
points on this curve
at different points in an economic cycle,
but we could also introduce an idea
known as a long run Phillips curve,
which is just based on the natural rate
of unemployment for this economy.
So let's say the natural
rate of unemployment
for this economy is 6%.
So, then our long run Phillips curve
would just be a vertical
line right over there.
Long run Phillips curve.
Now why is it a vertical line?
Well it says in the long
run, our natural rate
of unemployment is 6%
regardless of what the
inflation rate might be.
And so if we are sitting
at the intersection
of these two curves, that means
that our economy right
in this moment in time
is operating at full employment.
If unemployment was lower than that,
it would be overheating to some degree,
and if unemployment were higher than that,
then we would have a negative output gap.
But how do we tie these ideas
to aggregate demand and aggregate supply?
Well let's draw our long
run aggregate supply curve,
and I'm gonna do it
right at the intersection
of our aggregate demand and
short run aggregate supply curve
for now, because I wanna show an economy
that's operating at its full potential.
So here, this is our long
run aggregate supply,
and once again it's a vertical line
because in the long run,
regardless of the price level,
we have a certain output for this economy
that is sustainable.
So that is our full employment.
I'll do F, period, E, period.
That's our full employment output.
Anything more than
that, it's unsustainable
based on where the economy
is structurally right now,
and anything less than that,
is you have a negative output gap.
But now let's think
about what would happen
if we start shifting curves around.
What if we were to have
a negative demand shock?
So our aggregate demand
curve shifts to the left.
Well in that world, and
this is all a review,
you can see that your equilibrium price,
so I'm gonna call this
aggregate demand sub two,
our price level two, and
our new equilibrium output
for our economy sub two.
You can see that both are lower.
We now have a negative output gap.
But what would that correspond to here
on our Phillips curves?
Well, when you have a negative output gap,
you're likely to have higher unemployment.
And shifts in aggregate in
the aggregate demand curve
would be movements along the
short run Phillips curve.
So we're gonna move along
the short run Phillips curve,
and we're going to have
higher unemployment,
'cause we have a negative output gap.
So we might get to that
point right over there.
So I'll just call that point sub two.
So we went from a situation where before,
we had 6% unemployment,
and let's say we had 3% inflation,
to a world where maybe now, we have,
I don't know, let's
call it 9% unemployment,
and now we have 2% inflation.
And it could go the other way around.
Let's say we were
starting from our original
aggregate demand curve and you
have a positive demand shock,
and so now you could go to this curve,
aggregate demand three, and so here,
our equilibrium price level is higher.
It's called P sub three.
And our equilibrium output,
we have a positive output
gap, so Y sub three.
And that would correspond to,
if we have a positive output gap,
that means we have very low unemployment,
maybe unsustainably low unemployment.
So we might be right over here.
So this might be a situation
where our unemployment rate,
let's say that's about, I don't know, 4%.
And now our inflation, this might be,
let's call that 4% as well.
And something interesting happens
as you start to have higher
and higher inflation.
That can lead to people just
having higher expectations
for price and higher expectations
for inflation itself.
And if folks have higher
expectations for inflation,
well then they might wanna charge more
for a certain level of output.
So let's say at this level of output,
people might want to have
a higher price level.
At this level of output,
people might wanna have
a higher level price,
a higher price level.
And so it could actually shift
our short run aggregate supply up,
or you could say to the left.
So short run aggregate supply,
I'll call that sub three.
Now when the short run aggregate supply
gets shifted to the
left in this situation,
notice we're back to our
full employment output,
but our price level is now much higher.
Now what would that
correspond to over here?
Well when you have a shift
in short run aggregate supply curves,
that would actually lead to a shift
in your short run Phillips curve,
but which way would it shift?
Well another way to think about it is,
at a given, just as at
a given level of output
you would've expected a higher price
because of this increased
inflation expectations,
so here, at a given level of unemployment,
you would expect a higher
level of inflation.
So, our curve, you would say
shifts up or to the right.
So we would then have a short run
Phillips curve that looks like this.
I'll call that sub three.
And we might get back to this point.
Well for sure if were at
this full employment output,
then we are operating in our natural rate
of unemployment again, but notice,
now our inflation has crept even higher.
This might be 5% inflation.
Now the last thing you
might be wondering about
is when do these long
run curves ever shift?
Well we've talked about it before
when we talked about long
run aggregate supply,
and that shifts if the economy
structurally changes somehow.
Let's say our factories get bombed out
in a war or something, then
this should shift to the left.
And if we got better
technology, or better ways
of organizing ourselves,
or more resources,
this might shift to the right.
Similarly, if there's a
massive shift in global trade,
and maybe our workers' skills
aren't as valuable anymore
in the global economy, this
long run Phillips curve
might shift to the right.
If all of a sudden we are
able to, or over time,
we're able to get people more skilled,
maybe we get frictional unemployment down
because we have better
technology to place people,
well that might shift this to the left.